The Greek gods are notorious
for petty squabbling,
brutal punishments, and
meddling in people's love lives.
But in the myth of
Prometheus, an immortal
makes the ultimate sacrifice
for the sake of humankind.
A wily Titan who stole
fire from the gods
and gave it to humans,
Prometheus represents risk,
progress, and generally
sticking it to the man, Zeus,
who usually didn't take
kindly to any of those things.
Across world myth,
we find fire-seizing rebels
who defy the defying order
and ignite human potential.
Some are punished
while some are praised.
But what's so shocking about
stealing a little spark?
Prometheus is often
portrayed as a trickster.
But is that a fair depiction?
I think, and I'll die
on this cliff,
when you look closer,
Prometheus is a more
complex character
than you might expect.
[bright music]
To understand the
significance of Prometheus,
we have to go way back to before
the creation of humankind.
At this time, two groups of gods
were battling for
control of the cosmos.
The Titans, led by Cronos,
were the divine children
of heaven and Earth.
Shout out to the Gaia episode.
The Olympians, led by Zeus,
were a younger generation
of gods hungry for power.
These two mighty groups
seemed equally matched.
But the Titan Prometheus,
whose name means foresight,
saw that the Olympians
would eventually triumph.
He persuaded his
brother Epimetheus
to switch sides with him
just in time.
Sure enough,
Zeus defeated the Titans,
casting them into eternal hell.
As a token of his thanks,
Zeus gave the brothers
an important task--
creating life on Earth.
Epimetheus formed the animals,
while Prometheus shaped
the first humans from mud.
He made them
in the image of the gods,
but their bodies
were merely mortal.
Zeus saw these new-formed
humans as puny,
only good for worshiping
gods from afar.
But Prometheus
recognizes the dignity
in his fragile creations,
and he wanted
to give them an advantage.
When Zeus decreed that
humans should sacrifice
half an animal to the gods,
Prometheus killed an animal
and presented it in two parts.
Zeus chose the meatier part,
leaving the skin
and bones for mortals.
But when he examined the meat,
he saw that Prometheus
had hidden the succulent flesh
under the less attractive parts,
leaving only gristle
for the gods.
Furious, Zeus withheld
fire from the Earth,
leaving the first
humans hungry and cold.
But this only made Prometheus
more inclined to help us.
Scaling Mount Olympus,
he lit a torch from the sun god
Apollo's chariot, hid it
in a hollow fennel stalk,
and smuggled it
back down to Earth.
With fire, Prometheus
bestowed a powerful tool.
Now humans can nourish
and care for themselves.
But it also meant they could
forge weapons and wage war.
They learned new
skills, lived longer,
and traveled to faraway lands,
ultimately ruling above
all other living things.
Some on Olympus saw Prometheus
as a triumphant trailblazer
who gave mortals
the ability to progress.
Others viewed him
as a shadowy figure
who unlocked humans' appetite
for greed and conflict.
And others denounced him
as a supreme troublemaker
who needed to be taken down.
You can probably guess
what camp Zeus was in.
As punishment, Zeus bound
Prometheus to a remote cliff.
Every day, vultures
swooped down on him
and tore out his liver.
And every night,
his liver grew back,
ready to be devoured again.
In some versions, Prometheus
is trapped for eternity.
In others, Zeus eventually
allows Heracles to free him,
but only because he
needs Prometheus's help.
Despite his grizzly punishment,
we rarely see Prometheus
expressing remorse.
In Hesiod's "Theogony,"
he's a gleeful trickster
who happily flouts
Zeus's authority.
In a series of dramas usually
ascribed to Aeschylus,
he's a more cerebral figure
who waxes philosophical
about the boundary
between heaven and Earth.
And in the poetry of Ovid,
he's a visionary.
According to Ovid,
Prometheus shaped humans
with upturned faces so they
could look towards the skies,
and upright,
raise their face to the stars.
Here, it's Prometheus
that gives humanity
our thirst for knowledge
and the ability to
advance civilization.
These myths imagine
the transformation of fire
from a divine
or mysterious entity
into something that can be
hoarded, stolen, and shared.
But fire is never
an ordinary resource.
Rather, it gives humans the
power to light their own way.
Fire thieves are
dangerous figures
because they suggest that divine
authority is not absolute.
It can be tricked, twisted,
and in some cases,
seized for ourselves.
For transgressing the boundary
between heaven and Earth,
several Promethean figures
suffered grizzly fates.
Dating to the Bronze Age,
a Georgian myth
tells of the hero Amirani,
known for outsmarting
dragons and battling giants.
His downfall comes
when he tells humans
the secrets of metalwork,
which had previously been
reserved for the gods.
As punishment, Amirani
is chained to a cliff
in the Caucasus Mountains
where an eagle devours
his liver every day.
Amirani does have a trusty
dog who gnaws at his chains,
but every year, the gods
come back to repair it.
The Vainakh people
of the North Caucasus
also told of a demigod Pkharmat,
who stole fire from the heavens.
He pitied the humans,
known as Narts,
who had nothing but
cold milk and raw food.
The only source of fire
belonged to the god
of skies and storms, Sela,
who hoarded it in his chariot.
With the help of
Sela's wife Sata,
Pkharmat stole a blazing flame.
For all this, he was--
you guessed it--
chained to a cliff and
eaten by scavenger birds.
Crucially, Pkharmat
carried fire down to Earth
in a hollow reed.
Eventually, the fire burned
through its container
and made tiny holes,
creating the first reed pipe.
Thus, he brings not only fire
but music to humanity.
In this example, a Promethean
figure is associated
with creativity
as well as progress.
Although, while some people
refuse to recognize it,
Prometheus was
a creative himself.
Potter, activist,
artist, prankster,
whatever you want to call him,
it's hard to ignore his agency,
and that agency
inspires humanity.
The interpretation of Prometheus
as an imaginative spirit
was particularly popular
with the Romantics,
a group of writers,
artists, and intellectuals
who saw subjectivity,
individualism,
and emotional freedom
as paramount
during the 19th century.
Mary Shelley's husband Percy
wrote the romantic drama
"Prometheus Unbound," in
which the Titan is a hero
who spreads a message
of love and empowerment.
His friend, the poet Lord Byron,
also "stanned" Prometheus.
He wrote, "The godlike
crime was to be kind
and strengthen man
with his own mind."
Mary Shelley imagined Prometheus
as a more cautionary figure
in "Frankenstein,"
in which the titular scientist
makes a humanoid figure
and just can't deal
with his creation.
The novel is subtitled
"The Modern Prometheus,"
suggesting the danger of
tampering with the natural order
and the disastrous results of
misdirected human ambition.
To this day, Prometheus is
a shorthand for progress.
A quick Google will tell
you that a lot of companies
like to reference
the original disruptor.
But while billionaires who
want to fly to the moon
might market themselves as
pathbreaking Prometheans,
what sets them apart
from the real deal
is that Prometheus
was always fighting
for those less powerful
than himself.
In their ancient mythical forms,
Promethean figures
imbue humans with the
potential to reach new heights.
But they also stand in for
our hopes and anxieties
about what humans
do with their power.
Many also remind us
that with great power
comes great responsibility.
Accessibility provided by the
U.S. Department of Education.